alain claude lagier bonjour bonjour
madame cupide bonjour aux auditeurs de
martine premier rang vous êtes candidat
aux élections législatives
vous vous présenter dans la
circonscription 1 celle du centre
atlantique sans étiquette alors pourquoi
êtes vous candidat à ce scrutin
bien aujourd'hui je crois que il y à une
heure qui est arrivé le d'une certaine
génération qui doit aujourd'hui prendre
ses responsabilités parce que nous avons
forcément dix projets pour la matinée je
suis engagé en politique et dans le
monde associatif depuis très longtemps
depuis mon plus jeune âge et aujourd'hui
je crois que nous avons des messages à
porter je crois que la martinique a
besoin d'un projet je crois que les
électeurs ont besoin d'une vision pour
la martinique et c'est en ce sens que
des amis évidemment m'ont sollicité mais
aussi que j'ai fait le choix en toute
responsabilité de poser ma candidature
comme vous l'avez dit sans étiquette
aujourd'hui pour cette circonscription
numéro un
de la circonscription dans laquelle vous
vous présentez là le centre atlantique
quels sont pour vous les deux ou trois
priorités sur lesquelles vous comptez
plancher si vous êtes nationale à
l'autre ce qui est de conscription a
ceci de particulier qu effectivement
c'est l'une des plus grosses aujourd'hui
il y à 80 plus de 80 mille électeurs
succès ciconscription plus de 100000
habitants quasiment donc c'est une
circonscription forme et c'est aussi un
poumon économique puisque nous avons des
villes comme
lamentin aubert françois gros monnaies
trinité qui sont effectivement des
villes où il y a une vie économique et
faute donc ce qui est important
aujourd'hui pour l'électeur c'est son
pouvoir d'achat pour le citoyen
aujourd'hui à pouvoir d'achat et est
très très très en difficulté jeudi pour
les citoyens et donc ça doit être la
priorité il n'est pas acceptable que
aujourd'hui on achète une bouteille de
gaz à 30 euros il n'est pas acceptable
que lorsque vous faisiez un plein de
votre véhicule il y a quelques mois en
fin d'année dernière aujourd'hui vous
faites le même plan vous payer 30 euros
de plus tout ça c'est pas acceptable et
nous avons donc comme priorité de
travailler à améliorer cette situation
du pouvoir d'achat il ya aussi d'autres
problématiques la plus importante aussi
celle de la santé la santé du martinique
aujourd'hui nous avons l'impression
qu'il y à une sorte de génocide de cette
population concernant sa santé des
établissements de santé qui sont au plus
mal qu'ils sont délabrées vous avez des
problématiques prégnante comme la clau
des comptes qui a pollué notre sol tout
le monde en parle mais c'est une réalité
et qui empoisonnaient des générations
qui a tué des générations de martinique
il nous appartient donc de faire ce
qu'il faut pour que ces problèmes soient
prises en compte à leur juste valeur
vous avez aussi les sargasses qui elle
aussi tu tues et surtout sur notre
circonscription qui est particulièrement
cottier a plus que nous avons quatre
communes qui sont sur la côte et qui
subissent des sargasses et puis vous
avez effectivement dans ce domaine donc
de la santé de l'écologie qui vous
rejoins l'écologie aussi quelque chose
d'important qui fait que moi je dis
qu'il ya une forme de génocide de cette
population qui se meurt à petit feu
parce qu'il ya aussi cet exode des
jeunes effectivement régulièrement
qu'ils sont obligés de partir pour
trouver du travail donc des jeunes qui
portent des gens qui n'ont pas la santé
des gens qui ne peuvent plus rien
acheter kiki qui ont des difficultés à
survivre c'est une situation
catastrophique et il appartient à la
jeunesse du pays aux plus jeunes aux
nouvelles générations de prendre le
relais et de se battre pour améliorer la
situation des martiniquaises et des
martiniquais alors plus gros blanc plus
globalement concernant l'ensemble du
territoire avez vous d'autres priorités
sur lesquelles vous comptez plancher ma
priorité vous ne m'avez pas peut-être à
dessein poser le mot de programme ma
priorité parce qu'il ya pas de programme
pour un en tant que tel point
législatives on ne peut pas dire qu'on y
va fait aussi ça on a des orientations
et bien ma plus grande orientation ma
campagne mamam ma campagne est basée sur
ça sur lumes ma priorité c'est l'homme
et la femme anti nicaise il faut qu'il
soit pris en considération à leur juste
mesure parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
constatons que les l'humain est relégué
au second au second dans toutes les
décisions que ce soit pour les cision
économique on a l'impression que
l'humain doit à ses ovules économique et
pas l'un vers ce que ce soit pour la
situation écologique lui mais passent au
second plan la santé n'en parlons pas
puisque les les lobbys font ce qu'il
faut pour que et bien vous vous
consommiez des médicaments qui
effectivement ne nous améliorons pas la
santé loin de là donc c'est une
situation particulièrement difficile et
mon sens connectée c'est la femme et
l'homme antoni caisse dans leur ensemble
dans leur globalité qui doivent être
prises en compte dans toutes les
décisions qui sont prises au niveau
local et aussi au niveau national avant
de terminer à la claude lagier qu'avez
vous à dire aux eaux des aux électeurs
eh bien je dirais simplement aux
électeurs de cette 1ère circonscription
que lors du renouvellement des
générations est arrivé et que je crois
que nous avons déjà fait beaucoup
ensemble puisque j'ai beaucoup peuvent
jouer à pas mal de choses comme la yole
à l'unesco comme des manches contre la
violence comme la mise en place de
chantiers d'insertion et autres actions
pour la la population martiniquaise et
aujourd'hui nous faut passer à un autre
stade avoir des leviers différents qui
nous permettront d'aller plus loin dans
notre engagement pour notre vision pour
la martinique donc tout simplement fait
le bon choix le
le 11 juin prochain voter pour alain
claude l'âge et sa suppléante cindy
l'agent alain claude l'agît merci merci
à vous
[Musique]